j'ai juste récupérer antiphon pour
mettre un petit coup sûr qu'on voit mais
non non on verra et c'est ce qu'on fera
ses clones ans après je filmerai des
plans ok d'accord de faire du foot en
dessous mais si on suit aussi reçu au
quai bon ça va très bien je peux
t'appeler matinée whissell
[Musique]
je vous emmener avec moi aujourd'hui sur
une péniche pour venir vous parler de
samsung samsung a pas mal de nouveautés
galaxy note 10 no 10 plus on a déjà
parlé le test sort bien et on en passe
il ya également la watch actif deux on
va l'attesté le plus tard et aussi la
table 6 aujourd'hui on parle de cette
tablette abc stable est très haut de
gamme de samsung avec un stylet avec un
clavier je vous la présente vous allez
voir à la plains berthou on sera
peut-être une prochaine fois c'est
vraiment la découverte et à la vie celle
là elle va craquer plus d'une personne
très douce
ça va très bien mais bon on est
aujourd'hui sur une péniche pour parler
de nouveau appelé samsung oui alors il
ya le 10 mai ça on en a déjà parlé donc
aujourd'hui on passe un peu au tour mais
par contre c'est aussi une tablette car
il est tapé pas les 6 tab à 6 bon c'est
quoi la bm du produit alors laden du
produit c'est l'adn tabesse déjà ce qui
veut dire une tablette fine
ouais une tablette légère mais avec un
écran hors exceptionnels et des
performances rien que ça coûte des sous
ok je vais chez déjà gelé je pourrais je
m'habille par un procureur ni c'est cool
dont la en terme de finesse vu que j'ai
commencé par ça voilà on est sur une
tablette qui est très fine on retombe un
peu à nos amours de la table s 2 pour
ceux qui s'en souviennent
on puisse monter sur une tablette très
très fine très très légère pourrait avec
la tv ce taux a atteint 24 on avait
légèrement un peu d'embonpoint puisqu'on
était passé sur un dos en verre ce qui
nous avait et augmenter un peu
l'épaisseur à augmenter le poids ici on
peut voir qu'on est repassé sur un
design à lui c'est la vue du coup
derrière
exactement hockey est reconduit sur une
tablette de 5 7 mm d'épaisseur et fait
420 g géant voir
à prendre en main on ressent vraiment
sur quelque chose qu'on n'aura pas peur
d'emmener partout avec soi qui se fera
oublier dans un sac alors au niveau de
l'écran j'imagine de l'e3 mollet l'écran
bien entendu super amoled blessure de
2560 par 1600 pixels ce qui fait un
paquet de pixels je vous laisse faire le
calcul est génial c'est donc un très bel
écran bien entendu connaissent à
montréal sont là dessus de façon qui est
des prochains
tout à fait tout à fait on essaye de et
de rester au niveau parce que t'es pas
trop mal depuis la première tablette on
est sur du super amoled
on continue on l'améliorent petit à
petit s est ici on va voir vraiment ce
qui se fait de mieux aujourd'hui chez
nous 18,5 pouces on peut citer aussi le
fdr puisque la tablette est compatible à
terre vous quelqu'un a déjà su très
basses 4 c'est toujours le 4 août à
bercy
à éliminer luminosité qui a encore été
améliorée je raconte ça combien de près
on peut monter à 570 580 voix là pour
parler de cet écran qui occupe du coup
je ne sais pas si j'ai des chiffres mais
85% de la surface d'accord parce qu'à
l'aller face vers lui fait envie mais en
fait je pense que j'aurais même panier
que toute la soirée des classes ainsi
que tu m une hauteur qui va toucher et
après les gens ils ont touché ma bouche
je ne ferai pas ça en période de crise
alors j'imagine qu'au niveau de l'audio
tu dois on va toucher aussi j'imagine
les gens qui veulent du multimédia bien
entendu on a quoi on parle haut-parleurs
on reste sur dans la maison samsung
si je puis dire parce qu'on va voir des
haut parleurs qui sont développés par
image et cool on a commencé avec la tab
est roi ouais elle continue on
l'amélioré entendu à chaque fois
quelques là on va vers un son qui va
être encore plus puissant encore plus
riche et qui va nous permettre alors
joue peut-être
montrer et péter le sang mêlé what if
the musical
spécifique ou pas forcément mais nous
sommes stagne toujours en bien dans des
soirées presse comme ça tu mets un petit
renne stein ça mais tout le monde
l'ambiance on a quatre par la bonté
vraiment le son qui a réparé tous les
côtés tout à fait perdu 3 en poste pour
qu'on nous entende de bruce et ça je me
prendrai pas le droit d'auteur avec sa
note à 4 haut parleurs qui sont répartis
quelques autres joueurs exactement
autant vraiment une stéréophonie droite
ou à gauche et ce côté droite a deux
sources et le haut et le bas et le haut
et le bas tout à fait ok j'en profite
pour parler d'une petite fonction qui
est pas forcément connus ce qu'on
appelle chaîne de stéréo adaptatif ce
qui est vrai que quand on va tourner sa
tablette l'image va tourner mais le son
va tourner aussi ce qui fait qu'on va
toujours gardé garder le canal gauche à
gauche et le canal droite à droite
patrice bergues imagine pas deux prises
jack l'accord dakhla est sûre on va l'y
favoriser plus un casque gaz ou le
bluetooth
enceinte ou alors les quatre haut
parleurs qui font la loi qui ont la
faire on vient de voir ok très bien et
ça valait vraiment le côté multimédia
après le côté un peu plus productivité
qu'est ce qu'on va voir derrière dedans
comme ne pas alors ce côté trop alors
entre les deux en fait on va avoir déjà
le s pen la partie de l'attirail tabesse
depuis l'ata ps3 aussi et un s p qui va
être au niveau de celui d'une autre
cette année d'accord pourquoi je précise
ça parce que les années précédentes
parfois qu'on avait une génération
décalage c'est à dire que quand on
pouvait déclencher à distance avec
l'aspect dans une note 9
là elle ne pouvait pas forcément le
chrtr sur la tablette qui était sorti en
même temps d'accord ici on est vraiment
au même niveau ce qui veut dire que
quand on va vouloir prendre une photo
donc on va être dans ses menus
multimédia on va pouvoir faire tout ce
qu'on a fait venir les mouvements cas
erick torres peine de tomber exactement
au kenya plan
peuls alors donc il aime à le voir ou
sinon on peut le voir passer de l'un à
l'autre
j'y vois la droite gauche haut bas fait
même quand on est dans un temps du
multimédia par exemple sur vlc
on va pouvoir monter le son on va
pouvoir passer lui tu peux pas le loger
dans la table alors il ne loge pas
dedans la tablette mais il est aimanté
sur deux est exactement là je connais
hélas il ya la sagesse ou le métro donc
tout simplement ici à derrière peut le
voir des vertes un logement derrière
gêne un logement on peut voir qu'il est
légèrement marqué oui et pour vraiment
s'y retrouver on a ici une petite marque
sur le s pen d'accord petite marque sur
la tablette
on va venir les mettre en face ils
voulaient me voir qu'il est aimanté
cependant il en veut secouer un peu
on va voir que ça tient bien sûr si je
sue coup comme un âne bonjour les lois
de la physique sont là je fais
exactement hockey dans la mesure du
raisonnable ça va tenir hockey et ce qui
permet aussi là on peut voir une petite
animation
taklha on va venir logis rogers il se
recharge directement comme 70 euros
charge directement comme ça sans fil on
n'arrête pas le progrès jahia qui nous
permet du coup d'avoir toutes les
fonctions connectées dont on vient de
parler pour déclencher à distance au
hockey pour la technologie de ce s pen
et de la dalle on est sur la technologie
wacom
ok tout comme depuis toujours et tout
comme le note
copé qui va nous permettre d'avoir 4096
niveau de pression une pointe de 0.7 mm
je ne pas voir vous permettre d'être
très précis pour faire vraiment
100 kg fille par exemple on peut
vraiment les chercher le point de détail
pour sortir vraiment ce qu'on veut comme
un acte au moins je le démontrerai pas
étant donné que des qualités artistiques
sur le côté pour faire un petit loto tu
vois un petit truc exactement hockey une
saison le petit carré avec le triangle
je maîtrise on a même niveau on dans les
coulisses de la chaîne de meute est
brandon proctor je prépare des vies rôle
débit rôle volatiles exactement la watch
actif deux cas le petit cadran rotatif
qui fonctionne ainsi sur les brosses
bordure noire
il est très pratique pour le coup
vraiment romane et when you i'm série
fraîche shing comme on dit oui pour une
fille met donc en termes de pertes à
quoi dedans alors on est sur du
snapdragon auquel quel que soit le
marché
je précise puisque pour le note par
exemple pas le cas oui c'est sur le
marché us canadiens que nous sommes
récoltées seront ses chronos
correspondent exactement aux 1600
thunderbird pour tout le monde d'accord
avec 250 gigas de catch qu'est ce que
vous avez comme quand on a le 8 155
[Musique]
ce qui aujourd'hui ce qui serait mieux
sur le marché ok très bien tunisie en
termes de ram la ram j'en ai pas parlé
je parlais du stockage et 256 la
pâtisserie extensible par extensible
tout à fait on a ici le port microsd
alors nous communique sur 512 x 112
puisque c'est le maximum qu'on a pu
tester aujourd'hui d'accord mais on sait
que en termes de standards
théoriquement on peut monter à deux
terrains non parle de 512 puisque c'est
toujours n'a pu tester avec les cartes
en gamme chez samsung
ok ça veut pas dire que si des intérêts
sorte sur un peu plus tard chez sanction
ne sera pas compatible wii juste il
faudra qu'on leur test entre temps pour
pouvoir confirmer et du coup la rame on
est commandée et du coup sûr la ramener
sur 8 gigas de ram
parce qu'il permet quand même une usages
multi tâches puis littéraire
très fluide aucun problème entre le
processeur et la ram aussi pour les jeux
gourmands
on va pouvoir y aller il ya aucun
problème donc ça une tablette copa voire
en multi mais j'imagine donc du coup
fatalement pour son côté multimédia on
est au top pour le côté performances on
a ce qu'il faut derrière
côté dessin quand même bien aussi on est
au top
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour aller
plus loin en termes de productivité on
va pouvoir rajouter l'activboard rover
comme son indic c'est une couleur
qu'elle nous permette de protéger la
tablette mais entendu point numéro un
ouais et quand on va venir
la pause est ici on va déplier le corium
qui se tendent en fait ça fait comme un
petit stand exactement on est en deux
parties vraiment avec la partie clavier
et la partie protection est manquée et
on va pouvoir une fois qu'on est dessus
lancé le mode d'aix permet de retrouver
une interface type et c'est oui pourquoi
je dis type et c'est parce que parfois
on a eu la question ah mais ça veut dire
que je me retrouve avec windows non ce
n'est pas le cas on reste sur sa tv 6
avec le contenu coin à l'intérieur j'ai
des relations qu'on a un android qui est
conseillé de l'android
c'est juste une interface qui a été
repensé pour pouvoir être plus pratique
à utiliser avec le clavier et le
trackpad
on est sur un nuage on est sur manuel
tout à fait d'accord donc c'est juste à
l'inflation annuelle qui est optimisé
version ordinateur de bureau exactement
exactement
donc là je le montre avec le club a
retrouvé un peu tout à fait imaginer
quelqu'un qui me rend en bluetooth sa
souris et son clavier on va pouvoir tout
à fait raisonnable que lors de n'importe
quelle autre marque la coque aucun
problème avec ça c'est du ou plutôt ça
on est sur du bluetooth 5.0 en plus
flèche fait qu'on va avoir du multi
appairage ya pas de colère on est au top
donc là on va dans une autre rue de la
joie qu'on aura clavier qwerty mais on
pourra voir au clavier azerty tout à
fait alors le clavier français sera un
clavier azerty c'est juste qu'on a des
pré production ici et là on en arrivait
en partie puisque l'azerty est quand
même une exception française c'est ça
quand j'étais au culturel français on
aime quand même bien non très
particulier 29 hockey donc c'est bien
donc là tu vas vraiment touché je dirais
plus une public
particulier familiale qui veut faire la
petite bureautique exactement là on
peint pas forcément à la personne qui a
besoin d'avoir beaucoup de puissance de
travail et un gros pc pour faire les
montages pour faire des choses comme ça
même si les petits montages la petite
retouche photo on va bien entendu
pouvoir en faire oui vu qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur le cholestérol
applications comme lightroom et ainsi de
suite
absolument mais on n'est bien entendu
pas sur le niveau de performance que tu
dois te chope avec beaucoup de
performances bien qu rsquo rigole mais
155 bouyagui khadra mais après au delà
de sa soirée dès que tu veux faire un
peu de photoshop aller plus loin et 8 j
g belle blonde un peu plus ça ils se
trompent de cible et après tout dépend
le niveau 2
de professionnalisme qu'on peut
atteindre et surtout beaucoup de gens je
pense que ça serait amplement suffisante
ça c'est cool maintenant j'ai une
question
oui à l'autonomie l'autonomie alors sur
l'autonomie voilà 7040 midi en paire eur
ce qui est ce qui est quand même
vraiment conséquent après il faut pas
oublier qu'on est quand même sur un
appareil aussi qui est imposant avec un
gros écran qui va assommer en
communiquant rarement sur une autonomie
de 15 heures ce qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver sur notre site pour autant
mois sur l'autonomie j'invite toujours
apprendre beaucoup de pincettes parce
que personne exactement la même
utilisation de son appareil et personne
va avoir la même autonomie c'est ça on
pleurait essayé d'utiliser 10 fois son
appareil on va jamais avoir exactement
la même chose
c'est pour ça que je suis jamais très à
l'aise avec des données vraiment très
chiffré très bruts sur l'autonomie bon
écoute à un produit du groupe qui est
plus habituel familiale haut de gamme
exactement voilà aujourd'hui c'est le
meilleur de ce que sait faire samsung
sur la tablette à capri à un prix de 799
euros pour la version wifi hockey et 869
euros pour la version de catch 4g ok ça
fait un certain budget je réfléchis par
rapport à ce qu'on peut avoir notamment
une paire de ce trafic était canine gros
chien n'avait déjà pas mal on va plus
loin on a aujourd'hui ce qui serait
notre le ta gueule chez samsung
c'est un budget mais a voté sans d'un
excellent tic et enfin qu'est-ce que
vous allez vous mettre en face en saura
peut-être un peu
je vous compliquez dire ça mais par
rapport je pensais
c'est des choses qui sont un petit peu
ciblées ou alors est ce qu'on peut en
parler non parce qu'on n'aime pas faire
ce qu'on part et surtout la concurrence
nous on essaie de voir ce que nous on
est capable de proposer je suis
absolument d'accord n'a été comme le s
pen et cetera qui font partie de l'adn
et samsung depuis déjà 10 ans clairement
avec le premier galaxy note
alors je m'en vais le rester 2011 donc
un peu moins de 10 ans on va se parler
plutôt de 8 ans chez les grecs toi mais
a fait un petit moment
je vais place du consommateur moi moi je
me dis demain je vais acheter un produit
jeulin style et je pouvoir avoir mon
clavier avec je veux la performance dont
l'a clairement en termes de performance
et je sais juste qu'il faut enlever deux
jeunes impliqués top mais je dois me
poser la question si le consommateur
du coup quel va être l'atout de ce
produit là parce que tu ressens parler
d'apple est ok sans parler de qui que ce
soit du coup sans parler de qui que ce
soit avant parler de vue les choses les
atours pour les a déjà donné c'est
l'écran qualité les grandes enquêtes
mais les écrans aujourd'hui
on est reconnu mondialement pour la
qualité nos écrans on a des organismes
indépendants des journalistes etc qui
ont l'habitude de tester et de nous dire
d'années en années qu'on fait les
meilleurs écrans
donc c'est un des points numéro un avec
la molette notamment on y croit depuis
très longtemps nous le marché lui a mis
un certain temps à nous suivre sur la
tête
donc vraiment on a une expertise là
dedans
j'en reparle du coup mais le s pen le s
pen qui est quand même une spécificité
d'autant plus avec derrière un
partenaire qui est wacom quand même
puisqu'on est sur une technologie wacom
et tous les graphistes etc connaîtront
très bien la marque puisque c'est
utilisé pour du dessin professionnels et
ainsi de suite et ensuite derrière j'ai
envie de dire l'expertisé m'zungu au
sens large qui est dans les performances
puisque on donne aujourd'hui ce qui est
le meilleur avec un processeur
extrêmement puissant avec beaucoup de
ram avec beaucoup de stockage avec la
micro sd etc
voilà vraiment aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on sait faire de mieux et j'ai très
bien et on essaye de le faire le mieux
possible j'ai compris aux caisses à
votre écoute merci beaucoup produit
jusqu'au bout j'ai hâte de pouvoir le
tester et j'aime bien tout cas je trouve
ça vraiment soit et c'est vrai que on
sait que du point de vue audio
multimédia maîtrise des écrans et si
aucun problème on sait que le côté
espen est extrêmement bien maîtrisé le
fait d'avoir le clavier comme ça qu'ils
veulent c'est vraiment bien le produit
c'est un certain budget mais à côté de
ça quand on veut une nouvelle techno sas
prix aussi c'est normal au kenya merci à
toi merci beaucoup on peut le dire avant
[Rires]
je ne diffuse pas la phrase la face il
ne faut pas dire sur un gros but bon
alors c'est quoi un petit garçon raconte
tout moi je sais mais c'est bon ça un
petit gars c'est pas d'après hoffman ou
séparés c'est aurélien pédiatrie
mathieu crepel monsieur me voilà pour
cette petite vidéo on est pas mal on
prend l'air on se rafraîchit ça fait du
bien par où vous êtes prêt pour la
rentrée tout se passe bien comment vous
le trouvez cette dalle 6 pouvez vous les
pensez vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
est ce qu'elle vous botte est ce que
vous avez besoin d'une tablette on la
rentrée pour la productivité pour les
études pour le travail pour la maison
pour la famille il faut marquer tout ça
en bas en commentaire quant à nous on se
retrouve très bientôt pour parler de
samsung de plein d'autres trop vite donc
ça c'est vachement cool à bientôt vous
embrasse chaos
[Musique]